Let's kick things off with a quiz. Suppose I
take a normal distribution with this familiar
bell curve shape, and I have a random variable
X that's drawn from that distribution. So,
what you're looking at right now are repeated
samples of that random variable and as a quick
reminder, the way that you interpret this
curve, what the function X actually means
is that if you want the probability that your
sample falls within a given range of values,
say the probability that it ends up between
negative one and two, well, that would equal
the area under this curve in that range of
values. That's what the curve actually means.
I'll also pull up a second random variable also
following a normal distribution but may be this
time a little more spread out, a slightly
bigger standard deviation and here's the
quiz for you - If you repeatedly sample both
of these variables and in each iteration you
add up the two results, well, then that
sum behaves like its own random variable.
And the question is what distribution
describes that sum that you're looking at.
You think about it for a little moment... Maybe
you have a guess. Maybe you think, "I don't know,
it's another normal distribution or something with
a different shape." Needless to say, guessing is
not enough. The real quiz is to be able to
explain why you get the answer that you do.
In this case, if you have that deep to
your bones visceral level of understanding
for why the answer is what it is, you'll
be a long way towards understanding why
normal distributions serve the special
function that they do in probability.
Zooming out though, this is actually meant to
be a much more general lesson about how you
add two different random variables
regardless of their distribution,
not necessarily just the
normally distributed ones.
This amounts to a special operation that you
apply to the distributions underlying those
variables. The operation has a special name it's
called a convolution and the primary thing you and
I will do today is motivate and build up two
distinct ways to visualize what a convolution
looks like for continuous functions and then to
talk about these two different visualizations
can each be helpful in different ways with a
special focus on the central limit theorem.
After we do the general lesson, I want to
return to the opening quiz and offer an
unusually satisfying way to answer it. As
a quick side note - regular viewers among
you might know there's already a video
about convolutions on this channel. But
that one had a pretty different focus. We were
only doing the discrete case and I wanted to
show not just probability but the ways that
it comes up in a wide variety of contexts.
I mean, a slightly awkward spot because it
doesn't really make sense for that to be a
prerequisite to this video but I think the best
way to warm up today is to cover essentially
one of the same examples used in that video.
So, if you are coming straight from that one,
you can probably skip safely ahead.
Otherwise, let's dive right in.
For this opening quiz question, each of the
random variables can take on a value in a
continuous infinite range of values, all possible
real numbers. It'll be a lot easier if we warm up
in a setting that's more discreet and finite.
Like may be rolling a pair of weighted dice.
Here, the animation you're looking
at is simulating two weighted dice
and you can probably tell what's going
on but just to spell it out explicitly,
the blue die is following a distribution that
seems to be biased towards lower values. The
red die has a distinct distribution and
then repeatedly sampling from each one and
recording the sum of the two values at each
iteration. Repeating samples like this many
many different times can give you a heuristic
sense of the final distribution. But our real
task today is to compute that distribution
precisely. What is the precise probability
of rolling a two or a three or a four or
a five on and on for all possibilities.
It's not too hard to question. And
actually encourage you to pause and
try working it out for yourself. The
main goal in this warm up section will
be to walk through two distinct ways that you
could visualize the underlying computation.
For example, one way you could start to think
about it is that there are 36 distinct possible
outcomes and we could organize those
outcomes in a little six by six grid.
Now, if I was to ask you what is the probability
of seeing any one of these specific outcomes? Say,
the probability of seeing a blue four and
a red two, what would you say? We might
say it should be the probability of that blue
four multiplied by the probability of the red two
and that would be correct assuming that the
die rolls are independent from each other.
You might say that's kind of pedantic, of
course the die rolls should be independent
from each other. But it's a point worth
emphasizing because everything that we're
going to do from here moving forward,
from this simple example all the way
up to the central limit theorem assumes
that the random variables are independent.
In the real world, you want to keep a sharp
eye out for if this assumption actually holds.
Now, what I'm going to do is take this grid of
all possible outcomes but start filling it in
with some numbers. Maybe we'll put the numbers
for all the probabilities of the blue die down
on the bottom, all the probabilities for the
red die over here on the left and then we will
fill in the grid where the probability for every
outcome inside the grid looks like some product
between one number from the blue distribution
and one number from the red distribution.
Another way to think about it is we're
basically constructing a multiplication
table. To be a little more visual about all
of this, we could plot each one of these
probabilities as the height of a bar above the
square in this sort of three dimensional plot.
In some sense, this three dimensional
plot carries all the data that we would
need to know about rolling a pair
of dice. And so, the question is,
how do we extract the thing that we want to know,
the probabilities for various different sums?
Well, if you highlight all of the outcomes with a
certain sum, say a sum of six, notice how all of
those end up on a certain diagonal. Same deal
if I highlight all the pairs where the sum is
seven. They sit along a different diagonal. So,
to compute the probability of each possible sum,
what you do is you add together all of the
entries that sit on one of these diagonals.
Pulling up the 3D plot, we can better foreshadow
where we'll go with this later by saying that the
distribution of possible sums looks like
combining all of the heights of this plot
along one of these diagonal slices. It's
as if we've taken this full distribution
for all possible outcomes and we've kind of
collapsed it along one of the directions.
And admittedly, I'm just having a bit of fun
with the animations at this point. It's not
like if you are working this out with
pencil and paper you would be drawing
some three dimensional plot. But it's fun
when you collapse it on this direction,
you actually do get the same distribution. Which
I knew you should but it's still fun to see.
Also, even though all of this might just seem
a little bit playful or even unnecessarily
complicated, I can promise you this intuition
about diagonal slices will come back to us later
for a genuinely satisfying proof. But staying
focused on the simple dice case a little bit
longer, here's the second way that we could
think about it. Take that bottom distribution
and flip it around horizontally so that the die
values increase as you go from right to left.
Why do this you might ask? Well, notice now
which of the pairs of dice values line up
with each other. As it's positioned right
now, we have one and six, two and five,
three and four and so on. It is all of
the pairs of values that add up to seven.
So if you want to think about the
probability of rolling a seven,
a way to hold that computation in your mind
is to take all of the pairs of probabilities
that line up with each other, multiply together
those pairs and then add up all of the results.
Some of you might like think of this as a kind of
dot product. But the operation as a whole is not
just one dot product but many. If we were to
slide that bottom distribution a little more
to the left - so, in this case it looks like
the die values which line up are one and four,
two and three, three and two, four and one - in
other words, all the ones that add up to a five,
well, now if we take the dot product, we
multiply the pairs of probabilities that
line up and add them together, that would give
us the total probability of rolling a five.
In general, from this point of view, computing
the full distribution for the sum looks like
sliding that bottom distribution into various
different positions and computing this dot
product along the way. It is precisely the same
operation as the diagonal slices we were looking
at earlier. They're just two different ways
to visualise the same underlying operation.
And however you choose to visualize
it, this operation that takes in two
different distributions and spits out a new
one describing the sum of the relevant random
variables is called a convolution and we often
denote it with this asterisk. Really the way
you want to think about it, especially
as we set up for the continuous case is
to think of it as combining two different
functions and spitting out a new function.
For example, in this case, maybe I give the
function for the first distribution the name
P sub X. This would be a function that takes
in a possible value for the die, like a three
and it spits out the corresponding probability.
Similarly, let's let P sub Y be the function for
our second distribution and P sub X plus Y be the
function describing the distribution for the sum.
In the lingo, what you would say is that
P sub X plus Y is equal to a convolution
between P sub X and P sub Y. And what
I want you to think about now is what
the formula for this operation should
look like. You've seen two different
ways to visualize it but how do we
actually write it down in symbols?
To get your bearings, maybe it's helpful to
write down a specific example like the case
of plugging in a four where you add up over all
the different pair wise products corresponding
to pairs of inputs that add up to a four
and more generally, here's how it might
look... This new function takes as an input
a possible sum for your random variables,
which I'll call "S" and what it outputs looks
like a sum over a bunch of pairs of values for
X and Y except the usual way it's written is
not to write with X and Y but instead we just
focus on one of those variables, in this case
X letting it range over all of its possible
values which here just means going from one all
the way up to six. And instead of writing "Y",
you write S minus X. Essentially, whatever the
number has to be to make sure the sum is S.
Now, the astute among you might notice
a slightly weird quirk with the formula
as it's written. For example, if you plug
in a given value like s = 4 four and you
unpack the sum letting X range over all the
possible values going from one up to six,
then sometimes that corresponding
Y value drops below the domain of
what we've explicitly defined. For example, you
plug in zero and negative one and negative two.
It's not actually that big a deal. Essentially you
would just say all of these values are zero. So,
all these later terms don't get counted.
And that should kind of make sense - what
is the probability that the red dyed
rolls to become a negative one? Well,
it's zero, that is an impossible outcome.
As a next step, let's turn our attention
towards continuous distributions where your
random variable can take on values anywhere
in an infinite continuum, like all possible
real numbers. Maybe you're doing weather modeling
and trying to predict the temperature tomorrow at
noon. Or you're doing some financial projections
or maybe you're modelling the typical wait times
before a bus arrives. There are all sorts of
things where you need to handle continuity.
In all the graphs that we draw, the
X value still represents a possible
number that the random variable can take
on. But the interpretation of the Y axis
is a little bit different because no
longer does this represent probability,
instead the thing that we're graphing is what's
called "Probability Density. This is something
we've talked about before so you know the deal.
Essentially, the probability that a sample of
your variable falls within a given range looks
like the area under the curve in that range.
The function describing this curve is commonly
called a "Probability Density Function" - a
common enough phrase that it's frequently just
given the abbreviation PDF and so the proper way
to write all of this down would be to say that
the probability that your sample falls within
a given range looks like the integral of your PDF
- the probability density function in that range.
As a general rule of thumb, anytime that you
see a sum in the discrete case, you would
use an integral in the continuous case. So, let's
think about what that means for our main example.
Let's say we have two different random variables
but this time each one will follow a continuous
distribution and we want to understand their sum
and the new distribution that describes that sum.
You can probably already guess what the
formula will be just by analogy. Remember,
in the formula that we just wrote down where P sub
X is the function for the first variable and P sub
Y is the function for the second variable, the
convolution between them, the thing describing
a sum of those variables itself looks like a sum
where we combine a bunch of pair wise products.
The expression in the continuous case really
does look 100% analogous. It's just that we
swap out that sum for an integral. Sometimes when
students see the definition of a convolution out
of context, it can seem a little intimidating.
Hopefully, the analogy is enough to make it clear
but the continuous nature really does give
it a different flavor and it's worth taking
a couple minutes to think through what it means
on its own terms and so, I put together a little
interactive demo that helps unpack each part
of the expression and what it's really saying.
For example, the first term in this integral is
F of X, which represents the density function
for the first of the two random variables and
in this case, I'm choosing this sort of wedge
shaped function for that distribution
but it could be anything. Similarly,
G represents the density function for the second
random variable for which I'm choosing this sort
of double lump shaped distribution and in the same
way that earlier we went over all possible pairs
of dice values with a given sum, the way you want
to think about this integral is that what it wants
to do is iterate overall possible pairs of values
X and Y that are constrained to a given sum, S.
We don't really have great notation for
doing that symmetrically, so instead
the way we commonly write it down gives this
artificial emphasis to one of the variables,
in this case X where we let that value
X range over all possible real numbers,
negative infinity up to infinity, and the
thing we plug into the function G is S minus X,
essentially whatever it has to be to make
sure that the sum is constrained to be S.
So, for the demo, instead of graphing G
directly, I want to graph G of S minus X
and you might ask yourself "what is that
look like?" Well, if you plug in negative
X as the input that has the effect of
flipping around the graph horizontally
and then if we throw in this parameter, S,
treated as some kind of constant, that has
the effect of shifting the graph either left or
right depending on if S is positive or negative.
In the demo, S is a parameter that I'll just
grab and shift around a little bit. The real
fun comes from graphing the entire contents
of the integral, the product between these
two graphs. This is analogous to the list of
pairwise products that we saw earlier but in
this case, instead of adding up all of those
pairwise products, we want to integrate them
together which you would interpret as
the area underneath this product graph.
As I shift around this value of S,
the shape of that product graph changes
and so does the corresponding area.
Keep in mind, for all three graphs on the
left, the input is X and the number S is
just a parameter. But for the final graph on the
right, for the resulting convolution itself, this
number S is the input to that function and the
corresponding output is whatever the area of the
lower left graph is. Whatever the integral between
this combination of F and G turns out to be.
Here, it might be helpful if we do a simple
example. Say where each of our two random
variables follows a uniform distribution
between the values negative one half and
positive one half. So, what that looks
like is that our density functions each
have this kind of top hat shape where
the graph equals one for all inputs
between negative one half and positive one
half and it equals zero everywhere else.
The question as always is what should the
distribution for the sum look like. Well, let me
show how it looks inside our demo. In this case,
the product between the two graphs has a really
easy interpretation. It is one wherever the graphs
overlap with each other but zero everywhere else.
So, if I slide this parameter S far enough to the
left that our top graphs don't overlap at all,
then the product graph is zero everywhere and
that's a way of saying this is an impossible
sum to achieve. That should make sense
- each of the two variables can only
get as low as negative one half. So, the
sum could never get below negative one.
As I start to slide S to the right and
the graphs overlap with each other,
the area increases linearly until the graphs
overlap entirely and it reaches a maximum.
And then after that point, it starts
to decrease linearly again which means
that the distribution for the sum
takes on this kind of wedge shape.
And I imagine this actually feels somewhat
familiar for anyone who's thought about a pair of
dice. That is, unweighted dice. There, if you add
up two different uniformly distributed variables,
then the distribution for the sum has
a certain wedge shape. Probabilities
increase until they max out at a seven
and then they decrease back down again.
Where this gets a lot more fun is if instead of
asking for a sum of two uniformly distributed
variables, I ask you what it looks like if we
add up three different uniformly distributed
variables. At first you might say "I don't know,
we need some new way to visualize combining three
things instead of two", but really what
you can do here is think about the sum
of the first two as their own variable which
we just figured out follows this wedge shape
distribution and then take a convolution
between that and the top hat function.
Pulling up the demo, here's what
that would look like. Once again,
what makes the top hat function really
nice is that multiplying by it sort
of has the effect of filtering
out values from the top graph.
The product on the bottom looks just like a copy
of the top graph but limited to a certain window.
Again, as I slide this around left and
right and the area gets bigger and smaller,
the result maxes out in the middle but tapers
out to either side. Except this time it does so
more smoothly. It's kind of like we're taking a
moving average of that top left graph. Actually,
It's more than just kind of, this literally
is a moving average of the top left graph.
One thing you might think to do is take this
even further. The way we started was combining
two top hat functions and we got this wedge
then we replaced the first function with that
wedge and then when we took the convolution,
we got this smoother shape describing a sum
of three distinct uniform variables but
we could just repeat. Swap that out for
the top function and then convolve that
with the flat rectangular function and
whatever result we see should describe a sum
of four uniformly distributed random variables.
Any of you who watched the video about the
central limit theorem should know what to
expect. As we repeat this process over and over,
the shape looks more and more like a bell curve.
Or to be more precise, at each iteration,
we should rescale the X axis to make sure
that the standard deviation is one because the
dominant effect of this repeated convolution,
the kind of repeated moving average process
is to flatten out the function over time. So,
in the limit, it just flattens out towards
zero. But rescaling is a way of saying "yeah
yeah yeah, I know that it gets flatter
but the actual shape underlying it all?"
The statement of the central limit theorem,
one of the coolest facts from probability
is that you could have started with
essentially any distribution and this
still would have been true. That as you take
repeated convolutions like this representing
bigger and bigger sums of a given random
variable, then the distribution describing
that sum which might start off looking very
different from a normal distribution over
time smooths out more and more until it gets
arbitrarily close to a normal distribution.
It's as if a bell curve is in some loose
manner of speaking the smoothest possible
distribution and attractive fix point
in the space of all possible functions
as we apply this process of repeated
smoothing through the convolution.
Naturally, you might wonder why normal
distributions? Why dysfunction and not
some other one? There's a very good answer and
I think the most fun way to show the answer
is in the light of the last visualization that
will show for convolutions. Remember how in the
discreet case the first of our two visualizations
involved forming this kind of multiplication table
showing the probabilities for all possible
outcomes and adding up along the diagonals.
You've probably guessed it by now but our last
step is to generalize this to the continuous case.
And it is beautiful but you
have to be a little bit careful.
Pulling up the same two functions
we had before, F of X and G of Y,
what in this case would be analogous to the grid
of possible pairs that we were looking at earlier?
Well in this case, each of the variables
can take on any real number. So we want
to think about all possible pairs of real
numbers and the XY plane comes to mind.
Every point corresponds to a possible outcome
when we sample from both distributions.
Now, the probability of any one of these
outcomes, X Y or rather the probability
density around that point will look like F of
X times G of Y. Again, assuming that the two
are independent. So a natural thing to do is to
graph this function, F of X times G of Y as a two
variable function. Which would give something
that looks like a surface above the X Y plane.
Notice in this example how if we look at it from
one angle where we see the X values changing, it
has the shape of our first graph. But if we look
at it from another angle, emphasizing the change
in the Y direction, it takes on the shape of our
second graph. This three dimensional graph encodes
all of the information we need. It shows all the
probability densities for every possible outcome.
And if you want to limit your view just to
those outcomes where X plus Y is constrained
to be a given sum, what that looks like
is limiting our view to a diagonal slice.
Specifically a slice over the line X plus
Y equals some constant. All of the possible
probability density for the outcome subject
to this constraint looks sort of like a slice
under this graph and as we change around
what specific sum we're constraining to,
it shifts around which specific
diagonal slice we're looking at.
Now, what you might predict is that the way to
combine all of the probability densities along
one of these slices, the way to integrate them
together can be interpreted as the area under
this curve which is a slice of the surface. And
that is almost correct. There's a subtle detail
regarding a factor of the square root of two that
we need to talk about but up to a constant factor,
the areas of these slices give
us the values of the convolution.
In fact, all of these slices that we're looking at
are precisely the same as the product
graph that we were looking at earlier.
Here, to emphasize this point, let me pull up
both visualizations side by side and I'm going
to slowly decrease the value of S from two down
to negative two, which on the left means we are
looking at different slices and on the right means
we're shifting around the modified graph of G.
Notice how it all points the shape
of the graph on the bottom right,
the product between the functions, looks exactly
the same as the shape of the diagonal slice.
And this should make sense. They are two distinct
ways to visualise the same thing. It sounds like
a lot when we put it into words but what we're
looking at are all the possible products between
outputs of the functions corresponding to pairs of
inputs that have a given sum. Again, it's kind of
a mouthful but I think you see what I'm saying
and we now have two different ways to see it.
The nice thing about the diagonal slice
visualization is that it makes it much
more clear that it's a symmetric operation.
It's much more obvious that F convolved with
G is the same thing as G convolved with F. Now,
technically, the diagonal slices are not exactly
the same shape. They've actually been stretched
out by a factor of the square root of two.
The basic reason is that if you imagine taking
some small step along one of these lines where X
plus Y equals a constant, then the change in your
X value, that delta X here, is not the same thing
as the length of that step. That step is actually
longer by a factor of the square root of two.
I will leave a note up on the screen for the
calculus enthusiast among you who want to pause
and ponder but the upshot is very simply that the
outputs of our convolution are technically not
quite the areas of these diagonal slices. You have
to divide those areas by a square root of two.
Stepping back from all of this for a moment,
I just think this is so beautiful. We started
with such a simple question or at least such
a seemingly simple question - how do you add
up two random variables? And what we end up
with is this very intricate operation
for combining two different functions.
We have at least two very pretty
ways to understand it. But still,
some of you might be raising your hands and
saying "Pretty pictures are all well and good,
but do they actually help you calculate
something?" For example, I still have not
answered the opening quiz question about adding
two normally distributed random variables.
Well, the ordinary way that you would approach
this kind of question if it showed up on a
homework or something like that is that you would
plug in the formula for a normal distribution
into the definition of a convolution - the
integral that we've been describing here.
And in that case, the visualizations
would really just be there to clarify
what the expression is saying
but they sit in the back seat.
In this case, the integral is not prohibitively
difficult - there are analytical methods,
but for this example, I want to show you a
more fun method where the visualizations,
specifically the diagonal slices, will play a much
more front and center role in the proof itself.
I think many of you may actually enjoy taking
a moment to predict how this will look for
yourself. Think about what this 3D graph
would look like in the case of two normal
distributions and what properties that it has
that you might be able to take advantage of.
And it is for sure easiest if you start with
the case where both distributions have the
same standard deviation. Whenever you want
the details and to see how the answer fits
into the central limit theorem,
come join me in the next video.